- "Le pièce essentielle
du puzzle mythologique
qu'il créerait, Baderedine,
Alain et."."."
- Alain Farah, on se retrouve
dans la bibliothèque du Collège
Mont-Saint-Louis.
C'est un moment spécial pour moi
parce que j'ai étudié ici
cinq ans. Vous aussi.
- Oui.
- Pour moi, c'est ici que tout a
commencé, mais pour vous aussi,
d'une certaine façon, non,
dans cette bibliotque?
- C'est drôle parce qu'on s'est
jamais croisés à l'époque,
puis on s'y croise aujourd'hui,
comme quoi les livres nous
ramènent toujours un peu
à d'o o o on vient. Oui, le Cole
Mont-Saint-Louis, pour moi,
ça a été le début de tout,
si on veut. Je le raconte dans
"Mille secrets, mille dangers".
Avant d'arriver là, je savais
même pas, en fait, que j'avais
des origines étrangères jusqu'à
un certain point parce qu'à
mon école primaire, j'étais donc
avec des fils d'immigrants,
d'immigrantes, etc. Et là,
j'arrive ici et là, bam!
Tout d'un coup, je réalise que
j'ai pas les mêmes chaussures
que les autres, que mes cheveux
sont un petit peu plus crépus.
Puis, je vais dire quelque chose
de grave, mais qu'il y a
une table des ethnies.
(petit rire)
Et puis, à ce moment-là,
c'est tellement un choc,
et puis, ma réaction, c'est
de vouloir, jusqu'à un certain
point, me rapprocher de
la majorité. Et donc, tout
ce travail-là pour moi, ça été
un travail, jusqu'à un certain
point, de réinvention de qui
j'étais sans réaliser que
ce qu'on laisse de côté finit
toujours par nous rattraper.
- Nos racines, nos origines.
- Exactement. Exactement.
Oui, puis ça m'a pris du temps
à comprendre. Et je suis content
d'être allé jusqu'au bout
de l'expérience dans "Mille
secrets, mille dangers,
que l'exclusion, le racisme,
tout ça, on se le fait subir
à soi-même aussi, hein.
Donc, on peut aussi décider
qu'on ne veut pas faire partie
de ces communautés-là jusqu'à
ce qu'on réalise qu'il y a
une violence là inouïe.
Et donc, de développer, en fait,
une identité, ça a passé,
jusqu'à un certain point,
par le fait de changer d'accent.
Je pouvais pas changer mon nom,
je pouvais pas changer
la manière dont je m'habillais,
jusqu'à un certain point,
mais il y a eu cette envie-là
de pouvoir avoir les mêmes
privilèges que les autres.
Et donc, je ne réalisais pas
à l'époque que c'était
la mauvaise décision, dans
un sens. C'était la décision
que j'ai prise, mais il y en a
d'autres qui faisaient un autre
chemin en toute sérénité.
Mais en même temps, l'écriture
m'a permis de comprendre ça.
- "Mille secrets, mille
dangers", c'est l'histoire
d'Alain Farah qui vit le jour
de ses noces à l'Oratoire
Saint-Joseph et puis qui,
en fait, revisite son passé.
- Oui.
- Et dans votre livre,
vous parlez de Monsieur Cho,
qui était notre enseignant
de latin.
- Oui.
- Moi, Monsieur Cho m'a dit :
"Louis-Philippe, si un jour
tu veux devenir un homme,
il faut que tu dises l'Odyssée
d'Homère". Alors, qu'est-ce que
Monsieur Cho vous a dit à vous,
pour que vous deveniez grand
garçon, un professeur de
littérature à l'Université
de McGill?
- Il m'a dit : "Deviens ce que
tu es". Aussi simple que ça.
Il m'a dit : "J'ai confiance
en toi". Tu as... t'aimes
la culture, puis ta culture,
elle est faite de toutes sortes
de choses. Puis les jeux vidéo,
c'est ta culture, la télé,
c'est la culture. Puis deviens
ce que t'es, puis écris.
Puis il m'a encouragé à écrire
dans notre journal étudiant
qu'on avait à l'époque et puis
il m'a soutenu. Donc, c'est ça
qui rend aussi son destin si...
si tragique pour moi, puisqu'il
est décédé quelques semaines
après la fin de ma graduation.
- "Édouard s'engagea sur
Côte-des-Neiges direction sud,
mais il était ailleurs.
Il réécrivait l'histoire,
manipulait le temps,
reconfigurait les causes
et les faits."
- Et justement, dans "Mille
secrets, mille dangers",
vous êtes traversé par
deux douleurs. Cette peine
d'amour avec Constance et puis
aussi ces maux de ventre qui
vous assaillent constamment.
Et j'ai un peu l'impression
en lisant votre livre que c'est
cette douleur qui vous a permis,
tel le phénix, de renaître de
vos cendres. C'est un peu ça?
- Rimbaud disait : "J'ensevelis
les morts dans mon ventre".
Donc, cette idée-là que...
et puis on observe aujourd'hui,
il y a toutes sortes d'études
qui sont en train de définir
le fait que, justement,
le ventre, c'est un lieu aussi
où émotivement, il y a beaucoup
de choses qui se jouent.
Donc, j'ai l'impression,
en fait, que ça m'a appris
à développer une sorte de
sensibilité. Et puis, ça m'a
pris du temps à trouver
une surface, si on veut,
ou un endroit pour justement
en faire quelque chose,
de cette souffrance-là.
Et puis, ce qui s'est passé,
c'est justement, par le fait
d'avoir des encouragements,
par le fait de, tout d'un coup,
pouvoir me rêver autre chose que
ce petit gars malade, triste,
un peu... un peu différent.
Donc, il y avait un espace
tout dédié pour ça qui était
la littérature. Donc oui,
ça m'a permis de renaître
sous divers avatars aussi,
puisque mon travail, qui est
un travail sur l'identité,
réactive toujours un nouveau
Alain Farah, qui est un peu
comme un Tintin qui recommence
à chaque... ou un Astérix,
à chaque épisode, c'est-à-dire
où on peut réactiver sans passé
et sans avenir. Juste une espèce
de machine, si on veut,
qui surgit le temps d'un livre.
- On peut dire que c'est
votre semaine parce que, bon,
vous êtes finaliste pour
le Prix des libraires. On vient
d'apprendre ça. Et vous passez
samedi et dimanche au Salon du
livre de Montréal. On sait que
ce n'est pas toujours facile,
le Salon du livre, pour les
auteurs, ça peut être éreintant.
Mais comment vous anticipez
tout ça?
- Pour moi, disons,
le confinement a été pas mal
plus long que celui de la COVID.
Donc, ça fait comme 8 ans que
je me sens confiné, en écriture
de "Mille secrets, mille
dangers". Donc, de revenir
avec un roman comme ça,
puis de sentir depuis deux mois
l'enthousiasme du public,
donc, ça me remplit de joie.
Puis j'ai très, très, très hâte
de les retrouver samedi
et dimanche au Palais
des congrès.
- Alain Farah, merci beaucoup,
ça a été un plaisir.
- Merci.
- "Édouard se disait qu'en fait,
son cousin était plutôt
la lampe d'Aladin.
Le g